nous sommes ce qu'on appelle communément
des êtres particuliers jeunes à vous
avez 50 et une seconde de retard
excusez moi miss perry green comme une
carotte faut-il pour leur part pour
s'asseoir une selle les gens comme nous
sont persécutés depuis la nuit des temps
c'est pour cela que nous vivons dans des
endroits comme celui-ci j'appartiens à
une certaine catégorie les embrouilles
oui je sais les gens qui se transforment
en oiseaux
vous avez raison c'est exact mais ça ne
sert pas à grand chose
le principal talent du nombre une et la
manipulation temporelle nous choisissons
un endroit sûr et un jour tranquille et
nous créons une boucle je comprends pas
une boucle temporelle permet de
sauvegarder les dernières 24 heures si
on renouvelle la boue clic on peut de
nouveau vivre ces 24 ce recommence
chaque jour ces 24 heures tueur pour
l'éternité et on y résident à jamais à
l'abri du monde extérieur
toutes les ombres une s'engage à créer
et diriger un établissement tel que
celui ci
un foyer pour enfants particulier